somit das allerwichtigste weil die die
bogen skills länder seit jetzt auch
nicht so einen richtigen stelle bei mir
herzlich willkommen zu einer jolo runde
das ist eine runde wo ich spielen muss
und ich muss sie hochladen egal wie es
ausgeht auch wenn ich direkt am anfang
der box werde ich habe einfach so
traurig links geschrieben haben und auf
der defcon crafter jaja conny der ist in
der lobby so ist der hat sich umbenannt
und ich bin ja ne na.de und keiner kennt
mich an dem sind jetzt fertig auch alle
mal so ein bisschen so wie findet ihr
den denn wasser denn wirklich alles
klappt und ich muss das ganze jetzt
hochladen
egal ob ich jetzt direkt beim start
sterbe oder mich also video kann
theoretisch 30 sekunden gehen kann aber
auch eine halbe stunde dauern
das werde ich dann nicht mal zu conny
des hd ist coly foul
schön wäre es aber der will ich nicht so
ich mache sechs ein bisschen anders als
ich das schreibe das ist hammer geil
alter vermissen sie die leute verarschen
haha die glauben das auch noch mit conny
wie die glauben dass man kann nicht
verarscht mich nicht an die bulli des
bestimmt in diesem ding skater es klappt
nicht mehr so ein penner dabei ist das
was vier sekunden auf wenn dann lasst
ihn in ruhe
ok ich laufe laufe ich in dem mittel mit
richte ich habe keine anna die mir das
sagt okay bei gott ich habe einfach mal
fast gar nichts ok ich weiß auch nicht
wohin welche kisten hier sind willst du
ihn wie wegkommen weil das ist ja ne
runde
deswegen ich muss das hochladen ich
will's nicht 22 sekunden video hochladen
hier ist also als aber keiner hinter mir
deswegen was ist das eigentlich für ein
map alter ich habe ich hab noch nie
gesehen
wir sind ihr den kisten und sonst darf
kiste weiter nix drin aber geil aber in
bogen und pfeile habe ich selbst wenn
ich mich nicht als dumm anstellen was
ich natürlich tue reduzierung laufen
alter älter bin ich doch wenigstens
wüsste wo kiste sind dann werde ich
schon sonst schritt weiter lukan
brauchte wenn ich irgendwie im berg
hohen baum wirklich nicht die sind aus
der scheiße versteckt hier immer mehr
war halt stehen die so offensichtlich
des todes alle sagen so des todes mein
neues lieblingswort halten denn max voll
so wenn man hört dass auch voll schlecht
in einem akku voll so eingetrichtert
weil er das immer sagt richter ich bin
jetzt einfach mal oder da kommt unter
wasser fällt es eigentlich immer
die zahl der muss ich meine kids ugg ist
aber immer noch kein schwer aber leute
wir haben den jungen scheiß auf ketten
haube das viel scheiß auf ketten haube
alter werden die snap des todes leppek
des todes und goldene airmax alter egos
beschallt schreibt allen die kommentare
immer wenn ich was habe davon ist halt
das mappack des todes oder ich hab angst
was macht das mache dass ich ein
bisschen angst davor vor dieser schnur
egal ich laufe jetzt einfach dass nur
das nur so verschönerungen bin ich denn
ich hätte habe mich willkommen
wie wird es mache ich überhaupt alter
muss doch irgendwie look listen kriegen
ich brauch mal was zu feiern
ich brauche zum schlagen erstmal somit
das allerwichtigste weil die bogen
skills oliver nadine stähle bei mir auch
diese war es klar dass neue runde bei
mir genau 34 minuten doch und dann wegen
misst alter ich hatte die snack ist
todes bestimmt weil ihr das noch nicht
eine kommentare geschrieben habe
deswegen alte mann ist ärgerlich ich
hatte die snap des todes einfach nicht
das habe ich noch nie
na gut leute wenn ihr eventuell
normalrunde wollten ja vor kurzem wenn
ihr irgendwie kurz davor seit jetzt wie
ein kumpel zu fahren oder so oder zum
training oder keine ahnung euch einfach
mal noch kurz kommt braucht das runde
die immer unter fünf minuten bleiben
können dann geht man einfach den daumen
hoch und das hat auf jeden fall da wo
verdient diese geile hund mit shalit hd
und dann wird die fragen schreibt eine
goldene airmax in die kommentare wenn er
zum dran seid von dem man erst mal
wieder jungs